ja wir alle sind der meinung dass wir
los kommen müssen nicht erst seit der
russischen aggression in der ukraine von
fossilen ressourcen aber diese
schreckliche krieg hat uns gezeigt dass
wir jetzt schneller werden müssen dass
wir besser werden müssen und das heißt
wir müssen massiv investieren in
erneuerbare energien das tut diese
bundesregierung 200 milliarden euro
jetzt mit dem klima und transformation 2
damit wollen wir auch ganz konkret
helfen zum beispiel auch industrien
helfen wie der stahlindustrie den
chemischen industrie schwerindustrie es
gar nicht so leicht haben umzustellen
das heißt wir wollen gemeinsam pfade
finden unser industrieland eben auch fit
zu machen für die zukunft wir wollen
aber auch nach vorne steuern das heißt
dass wir auch themen wie zum beispiel
das tempolimit auch wenn das gescheitert
ist in der koalition nicht aufgeben
werden dh es muss möglich sein dass wir
auch mit einfachen maßnahmen für den
klimaschutz was tun das auch die städte
dafür sorgen dass in den städten weniger
auto gefahren wird in dem ein besseres
angebot schafft indem man die leute dazu
zwingt weniger auto zu fahren das heißt
klimaschutz ist eine mitmach aufgabe und
das thema energie einsparen muss ich
auch ganz wichtig jetzt sein denn wir
wollen ja dass der boden nicht so viel
geld kriegt von uns dadurch müssen wir
weniger verbrauchen beim gas beim öl und
auch bei der kohle und das geht nicht
nur einkaufen sondern den wir auch
weniger verbrauchen da gibt es
intelligente maßnahmen wie zum beispiel
intelligente stromzähler in den
heizungen etc also wir können ganz viel
tun gemeinsam anpacken
herr frei sie sind ja in der opposition
haben sie was dagegen zu sagen dafür
ihre meinung ist natürlich sehr fein
interesse nein also grundsätzlich ist
der befund ja absolut richtig die frage
ist wie man damit umgeht und da gibt es
jede menge zu kritisieren also zunächst
einmal glaube ich muss man aufpassen
dass man nicht nur windkraftanlagen in
die landschaft stellt sondern dass man
den da erzeugten strom auch tatsächlich
nutzen kann besetzt leitungssysteme
voraus die wir häufig nicht haben und es
sind trassen probleme die wir jetzt
schnellstmöglich lösen müssen damit wir
tatsächlich auch in der lage sind auch
ein konventionelles kraftwerk mal vom
netz nehmen zu können und
regenerative energie wirklich zu nutzen
und ich will ein praktisches beispiel
aus meiner heimat nennen wir verhandeln
dem bundestag gratis oster paket der
bundesregierung und in diesem muster
paket das eigentlich verbesserungen im
bereich der regenerativen energie
bringen soll
wird beispielsweise die förderung für 90
der
wasserkraftanlagen
auf null gestellt das bedeutet im
klartext dass man eine regenerative
energieform die anders als sonne und
wind dann zur verfügung steht wenn man
sie auch braucht im grunde genommen
einfach abstellt und die wasserkraft ist
jetzt sicherlich nicht die ganz große
regenerative energieformen in
deutschland aber sie können damit eine
million haushalte in deutschland
versorgen und das ist etwas was ich
nicht verstehe aufgrund des ukraine
konflikt steuern wir auf eine schwierige
situation zu weil die regenerative
energien ausreichendem maße eben nicht
schnell genug zur verfügung steht und in
einer solchen situation
möglichkeiten vom tisch zu nehmen wie
beispielsweise die wasserkraft wie
beispielsweise auch das was an strom
erzeugt wird durch die letzten drei
verbliebenen atomkraftwerke die bis ende
des jahres planmäßig noch am netz das
halte ich wirklich für fahrlässig und
deswegen ist diese politik der
bundesregierung sehr auf dem moment
gerichtet aber es fehlt wie bei fieber
verwendeten eben das gesagt die union
verabschiedet es geht
es geht nicht um die frage da hatten wir
tatsächlich einen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen konsens so habe
ich das immer empfunden
auch die cdu einen einen blackout würde
ich jetzt ich will das ja gut dann habe
ich in meine meinung ich würde es auch
nicht zurückdrehen sondern es geht
schlicht darum es sind in deutschland
noch drei atomkraftwerke am netz die
sind für etwa fünf bis sechs prozent des
stromverbrauchs in deutschland
verantwortlich und ich halte es für
unverantwortlich die ausgerechnet am
31.12 dieses jahres abzustellen wenn wir
in dem nächsten und vielleicht auch im
übernächsten winter noch in einer
situation sind wo wir im zweifel nicht
alles an ich habe die gesamtheit der
union halten sie damals nach wie vor für
richtig weg wie war richtig die bleibt
richtig und die wird auch nicht rück
abgeben kann man es müsse noch ein
bisschen gucken dass wir auch das
richtige reden wir heizen der in
deutschland ist nicht mit strom sondern
mit gas und öl das heißt die atomkraft
das ist stehe ja geringen
möglichkeitsraum da noch eine wende zu
schaffen sollte es zu einer rangelei
gekommen wir immer gesagt dann
das ist doch der rasen wir müssen
nämlich rein dass wir die prozesse
energie in der industrie schaffen dass
wir die versorgungssicherheit sicher
stift das wird den nächsten winter der
nächste winter den sicher stellen wir
sicher in dem was gucken
energieeinsparung muss auch kommen bei
den haushalten und industrie wie kaufen
ja wie verrückt ein auf der welt auch
dort wo werden die wollten sie haben
recht das sind auch nicht ländern
demokratisch uns gefallen ich kann uns
jetzt helfen situation ja wir sind einer
meinung dass wir weg wollen von putin
glaube ich da sind wir dann gemeinsam
das heißt in diesem jahr müssen wir
solche krisenmechanismen einschalten
aber wir sind gleichzeitig dabei ist
mich mal ganz deutlich sagen wird also
auch sagen den menschen in katar geht es
besser als noch russland davon gehe ich
aus ich war ja schon mal dort auch mit
sigmar gabriel vor sieben jahren und das
war auch keine einfache reise aber das
ist trotzdem auch ein nicht einfaches
land trotzdem wir wollen ja deswegen weg
damit der putin seine waffen nicht mehr
finanzieren kann jetzt mal ganz kurz
windkraft und photovoltaik geht drei und
vier mal so hoch dann ab 225 das heißt
da kommen die kapazitäten wasserkraft
schauen wir uns an auch die kritik aus
der branche ich komme aus bayern viele
kleine wasserkraftwerke gibt es auch wir
bringen nicht die bringen nicht die
masse sie werden sicherlich nicht der
game changer wie man so schön sagt aber
natürlich müssen wir uns angucken das
wenn leute investiert haben dass sie
vielleicht auch in der zukunft ist
weiter können also die diskussion ist
weiter offen
haben sie ja auch da würde ich gerne
würde man
ja nicht genau vor die tür aber nah dran
finden sie das eigentlich richtig dass
ihr eigentum direkt so eigentlich auch
entwertet widmen windkraft im bereich
findet es grundsätzlich schwierig dass
wir jetzt das ganze land voll pflastern
mit mit windrädern
ich habe bin jedes mal erschrocken
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich in den
schwarzwald wieder runter fahre um eine
verwandtschaft zu besuchen weil
inzwischen auf jeder bergkuppe
überall windräder stehen früher hat man
gesagt wenn lässt natur unberührt jeder
von uns weiß was wir wie viel beton da
in den boden gegossen wird irgendwie
wenn sie in ihrem eigenen garten einen
baum fällen dürfen sie das nicht aber
für ein windrad irgendwie schneiden wir
auch schneisen in naturschutzgebiete ist
alles drin würde ich will doch hat ja
ich will nur sagen wie ich möchte gerne
von dieser illusion eigentlich runter
dass man glaubt man könnte ein land wie
deutschland sicher mit energieversorgung
und zwar nur mit regenerativen energien
und ich werde ich bin absolut bei ihnen
dass es wahnsinn ist in dieser situation
die atomkraftwerke die wir noch haben
abzuschalten ich halte es aber auch
grundsätzlich für einen wahnsinn dass
wir als im endeffekt ist deutschland ja
ein geisterfahrer in diesem bereich auch
weltweit wir hatten einmal die
sichersten atomkraftwerke weltweit und
haben im alleingang sie abgeschaltet und
es will niemand wirklich darüber
diskutieren weil dieses eisen keiner
anfassen will aber sorry wir müssen
eigentlich also es kann ja auch nicht
sein dass wir nach dem motto wir wollen
jetzt gas nicht mehr bei guten kaufen
dafür kaufen wir es in katar was machen
wir wenn die eigentlichen krieg beginnen
dann suchen wir uns jemand heute
geschrieben nein ich bin ja mit den
rohstoffen aber das ist ja genau das
ding deutschland ist energiepolitisch im
prinzip völlig angewiesen auf seine
freundlichen nachbarn und auch
freundliche lieferanten das heißt und
wir wissen heute dass energiepolitik
inzwischen auch eine sicherheitspolitik
geworden ist sogar das heißt da muss man
doch einfach sagen sie waren solche
deutschland ist im endeffekt völlig
aufgeschmissen und ist hat seine eigene
unabhängigkeit in diesem bereich schon
lange aufgegeben und und ich möchte sie
wieder aufbauen das geht aber nicht mit
windkraftanlagen und mit solarzellen
sondern da brauchen wir auch vernünftige
kraftwerke und wenn sie die fossilen
abstellen wollen dann brauchen sie
atomkraftwerke das ist eine ganz
einfache rechnung ich möchte gerne
darüber diskutieren auch unter dem
aspekt energiepreise die jetzt schon für
die bevölkerung eine zumutung ist
während sie im ausland billigen
atomstrom haben können schalten wir in
deutschland ab und erhöhen noch weiter
die die hohen strompreise die wir in
deutschland die wir sowieso im
europäischen vergleich haben ich finde
das unverantwortlich ist die entsorgung
am ende ja nicht dann müssen sie ja noch
die zweite entsorgen meine
windkrafträder aber wenn ich mal was
sagen ja
in bayern heute industrieansiedlung
machen dann sagen die mir wir gehen da
nicht mehr hin weil im norden ist die
windenergie so ist mittel der ganze die
ganze situation hat sich geändert wenn
sie nach dänemark hoch gehen da ist ja
noch viel mehr wind also windenergie in
rauen mengen ist schon die zukunft und
die leute wollen das auch vor ort sehen
in der mehrheit das nicht
ich finde das schön also ich hab da so
genannte ich würde auch nicht
ich habe keinen eigentlich wohl das
großstädten aber ich
kam ja auch gar keins hingestellt hätten
wir jetzt vorwerfen aber
windräder wirklich schön wenn ich so
sehr freue mich über die in der
landschaft auch ja